Here’s a challenge for you: After you finish
watching this video, go to your kitchen and
open the fridge.
Then, try to find something that has been
produced outside of your country.
And if you’re watching this video from a
European Country, try to find some product
produced outside of the European Union.
I bet you can’t even find one.
Doesn’t it surprise you?
Well, think about it… your Mobile phone
has been manufactured in more than 20 different
countries.
The pants you’re wearing right were manufactured
in a country like China or Bangladesh.
And maybe the company you work for is also
foreign.
No surprises here, right?
We all agree that we live in a globalized
economy.
Nonetheless, food is the exception to the
rule.
Agriculture is an industry that is completely
protected from foreign competition.
And make no mistake: this has nothing to do
with Donald Trump.
In fact, if you think he’s the creator of
trade wars…
Well, you’re absolutely wrong.
Actually, the primary sector exists in a never
ending cold war.
That’s why, from time to time, we see headlines
like this one…
Trade War Rips Through Farm World; Soybean,
Hog Prices Fall
Or this other one…
EU cuts import tariffs in a bid to end 'banana
wars'
But there are more than tariffs here.
In fact, tariffs are just one of the many
tools used to attack foreign markets.
And it’s not even the deadliest.
Here’s an example: America spends more than
20 billion dollars a year in subsidies for
their farmers.
Sound like a lot?
Well, not compared to the whopping 72 billion
dollars that the EU spends in subsidies every
year.
And now you might wonder… but what do subsidies
have to do with trade wars?
The answer is…
A LOT!
For example, this milk break you see on the
screen is worth an average of 60 euro cents
in a Spanish supermarket.
From those 60 cents, the Spanish farmer would
get 30 cents.
But his actual revenue is going to be 44 cents.
Why?
Because the European Union will give him a
subsidy of 14 cents per liter.
Thanks to this Grant, the farmer can sell
cheap and still make Money.
And this is why Europe doesn’t need to buy
African sugar despite it being cheaper.
Or even more surprisingly, why American or
European producers can smash the competition
in African markets despite having higher wages.
But wait a minute because things are about
to change.
And this time, the free market champion is
not America, nor Japan, nor Australia…
My dear viewers, despite what you might expect,
if there is somebody willing to start an agricultural
liberalization, it’s the EUROPEAN UNION.
Emmanuel Macron breaks French taboo on farm
subsidies
A French President questioning the subsidies
on farming is like… a hipster closing his
instagram account.
Something never seen before.
For years, the so called, “Common Agricultural
Policy”, also known as the CAP has been
one of the pillars of the European Union.
And France is, by far, its biggest supporter.
But, as I said, things are about to change.
So now the question is…
Is Europe ready to liberalize its agricultural
sector?
Are we about to see the end of the food trade
wars?
And most importantly of all… is this good
or bad news?
In this video, we are going to answer all
of these questions but, before we do, let’s
take a look back at history.
WHAT IS CAP USED FOR?
Let’s imagine we have a wheat farm in ESSEX,
in the United Kingdom.
We harvest the crop and go to sell it to the
market.
Last time we did, we received 175 Pounds per
ton.
So it makes sense to expect to sell it for
a similar price this time around, right?
Well… no.
This time, maybe the market price for wheat
is just 150 pounds per ton.
This is the reality every farmer faces every
year.
By contrast, the price of an iPhone doesn’t
change much over time, so if we sell iPhones,
we can make good predictions about our income.
But wheat, corn, oil or any other commodity
can change their market price from one day
to the other.
And now you might wonder…
why?
What’s the difference between wheat and
an iPhone?
Well, the difference is that commodities are
the same everywhere.
Did you eat bread today?
Could you tell me where the wheat it was made
from was produced?
Almost certainly not.
The same goes with the oil used to produce
the gasoline you put on your car.
You don’t know if it is Saudi or Canadian
oil and… you don’t care.
You just want it to be as cheap as possible.
Nonetheless, there are just a few dinosaur
juice producers…
while wheat, corn and potatoes can be harvested
anywhere.
So, if one big producer had a good harvest…
that’s going to affect the market price
for everybody.
Add to this the weather.
Too little rain, too much rain, or an unusually
cold winter can be enough to kill off all
of your revenue.
Nonetheless, we need agriculture because,
unfortunately, you cannot eat dinosaur juice
or iPhones.
So how can we keep eating while farmers don’t
starve?
This might seem like a stupid question, but
believe me, it is one of the hardest problems
in economics.
And this is where the Common Agricultural
Policy, also known as the CAP, comes into
play.
This is how the European Union protects their
farmers.
When we talk about CAP, we’re talking about
the cornerstone of the European Union.
It was a thing even before the Schenghen area
or the Eurozone where born.
Actually…
do you know who was the actual father of the
CAP?
Exactly!
The former French president, Charles de Gaulle…
“A nation has no friends.
Only interests.”
–Charles De Gaulle.
If you’ve been subscribed to VisualPolitik
for a long time, you already know that Charles
de Gaulle was not a big fan of the free market
economy.
Well… he wasn’t a big fan of anything
except himself, really.
This is why, when France became a member of
the European Single Market, what later would
become the European Union, he added a condition.
“OK, we’ll sign up here buuuut, you gotta
promise us that nobody is gonna become competition
for our farmers”.
And this is how the CAP was born: a policy
that is so interventionist, it makes Bernie
Sanders look like Warren Buffet.
Basically, in order to compensate for potential
loses when market prices go down, the European
Union gives them direct cash.
For example, if you have a barn with cows
in Spain, Brussels will give you cash straight
away for each cow you own.
And if you wanna buy a milking machine that
is going to make you more productive…
Brussels will help you too.
This way Europe is not guaranteeing your income.
It is also helping protect you from American
or African producers.
And as you might have already imagined, all
this aid costs a shitload of money (read it
as it is so I can censor it).
If you wanna get a better idea, during the
90s, this CAP comprised 80% of the whole European
Budget.
And now that Europe is bigger and has more
things to do, CAP still makes up 40% of all
EU spending.
And… surprise surprise!
Guess which country receives the most aid!
Of course, that would be…
FRANCE!
But wait a minute because things don’t stop
there.
Beyond direct aid, Europe has other tactics
to avoid price fluctuation: quotas and tariffs.
For example, in order to avoid a price drop
in milk, Europe used to but a production limit
on each country.
That means that you couldn’t produce more
than a certain number of liters.
And, of course… who was benefiting the most
from those production quotas?
You can guess… the country of croissants
and baguettes.
As you can imagine, this milk quota created
all kinds of problems among the other members.
And this is why, despite French pressure,
Europe had to put and end to this.
END OF
EUROPEAN MILK QUOTAS: A NEW ERA FOR THE FRENCH
DAIRY SECTOR
And, of course, we also have the tariffs.
Tariffs are like sniper bullets to stop very
specific products from getting into European
markets.
For example, imagine that you are an Argentinan
coffee producer.
If you want to sell your RAW coffee, meaning
you take it from the plant and sell it, Europe
has no problem.
0 tariffs for you.
Why?
Because no European country grows coffee.
But, oh boy!
If you want to sell this coffee already toasted
and processed…
good luck!
You will have to pay a tariff of 7.5%.
Why?
Because Europe has factories that process
and toast coffee.
And they don’t like competitors.
But I know what you’re thinking!
Oh, that evil European Union is punishing
the third world!
Those Brussels bureaucrats want to destroy
free trade!
Well, I have bad news for you, guys… the
truth is EVERY country on this planet does
the same thing.
In fact, when it comes to tariffs, Europe
is one of the most open regions.
For instance, if this Argentinian farmer wanted
to sell his processed coffee in Japan, we
would pay a 20% tariff.
If we wants to sell bananas, then we has to
pay between 40 and 50%, depending on the season.
And what about America, the land of the free?
More or less, the same.
Almost no country is willing to leave its
farmers alone to compete in a fair competition.
Nonetheless, all of this can change.
Why?
Let’s have a look.
BAD TIMES FOR PROTECTIONISM
Every year, Europe spends over 72 billion
dollars subsidizing its own farmers.
But, as you can imagine, not all the country
members pay the same amount.
Just look at the chart.
Here you can see the main net contributors.
That is, the countries that pay more than
what they get.
And surprise!
Surprise!
Who is the third biggest CAP net contributor?
Of course, that would be the United Kingdom,
the country that will no longer be a member
of the club.
As you can imagine, that leaves a hole of
more than 12 billion euros.
This is why many are suggesting that other
countries have to start paying more to keep
the spending where it used to be.
European Commission urges EU countries to
pay more into budget
Nonetheless, who wants to pay more?
At a time where euroskeptic parties are stronger
than ever, no politician wants to come back
to his own country saying “hey guys, take
out your wallet because now we gotta pay more
for being in the EU”.
So… if you do the math, you realize that
there is just one option left.
Brussels plans to cut its payments to Europe’s
biggest farms
Basically, Europe had to reduce the direct
aid given to the farmers.
And they have started with the wealthiest
ones, since they’re the ones who needed
them the least.
But the biggest surprise came with Emmanuel
Macron’s speech.
Everybody in Brussels might expect France
to come out as the biggest old school CAP
supporter, right?
But Macron has other priorities.
And this means a green light to cut aid in
the future.
Meanwhile, trade deals are in fashion.
EU and Mexico agree new free trade pact
Yes, yes, yes… and we are not only talking
about Mexico.
Look at this news…
The European Union rushed to promote its preliminary
free-trade agreement with Japan by stressing
the benefits for EU farmers
Yes, my dear viewers, slowly, the European
Union is reducing subsidies, reducing tariffs
and getting rid of production quotas.
And I know what you are thinking now…
Come on, Simon!
Are you telling us that BREXIT is the only
reason for this change?
Of course not!
In fact there are two other important reasons.
On one hand, European Agriculture is already
more productive than elsewhere.
In this video, we told you about the Netherlands
being one of the biggest agricultural powerhouses.
In fact, they have what we can call the Food
Silicon Valley.
But they are not the only ones!
Food exports can’t stop growing.
In fact, things like Camembert Cheese or RIBERA
DEL DUERO wine can be found almost everywhere.
And they come from Europe.
In other words, Europe doesn’t need to protect
its own market anymore but, instead, sign
lots of trade deals.
And I know what you might be wondering now…
Will farmers be happy when they stop getting
all those subsidies from Brussels?
Most likely…
no.
But, the question is…
Does it really matter?
Look, Peasants unions used to have a big political
grip.
During the 60s, when De Gaulle was the French
President, France had millions of people working
in the primary sector.
Now, they aren’t even 3% of the population.
This means way less political sway and way
less votes.
But not only that!
Who do you think those European farmers vote
for?
France's disillusioned farmers turn to Le
Pen
Exactly!
Generally speaking, the biggest place for
euroskeptic parties to get their votes is
the rural areas, where farmers live.
So if you’re a European politician and you
want to make your voters happy… you wanna
pay more attention to the urban, Europeanist
voters, instead of the rural, euroskeptic
ones.
And your average city guy doesn’t even know
what the CAP is all about.
That is why today’s question is…
Does the CAP have any future whatsoever in
Europe?
Will we see greater liberalization of agriculture
in Europe and the rest of the world?
Please, leave your answer in the comment section
below.
Also, visit RECONSIDER MEDIA, the podcast
that provided the voices in this episode that
were not mine.
And don’t forget to check out our PATREON
page where you can support our channel and
gain access to exclusive content.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and, as always…
I’ll see you next time.